(inquisitive music)
- So, if you've been looking to fly
from America to Europe this year,
you'll have noticed that there's
a whole bunch of airlines
that seem to suddenly be
offering very cheap fares.
Airlines like Norse, French Bee, and Play
have all been trying to capture a wave
of post pandemic revenge
spending transatlantic travelers
by trying to lower their ticket
prices as much as possible.
And their tactics go far, far further
than just charging for the seats
and separating out added extras.
- It's more about getting
every part of your business
at the lowest possible costs.
- But major legacy airlines
are competing hard on pricing, so much so
that sometimes they even
undercut the low-cost carriers.
And now with winter around the
corner and demand set to fall
there's a huge question
over the long-term viability
of low-cost transatlantic flight.
So are these airlines and their airfares
set to disappear as
quickly as they arrived?
Let's find out.
Okay, so first I want to know
how these low cost airlines
are getting their ticket prices down.
And so to do that, I've come
to visit Norse Atlantic.
The company was formed in
Norway after the pandemic
and has 15 of these
Boeing 787 Dreamliners,
10 of which it currently
operates from America to Europe.
Now, part of what helps
Norse get its prices down
is by doing something called
unbundling ancillaries,
which in plain English is
basically charging separately
for everything other than the seat.
Flying its most basic fare,
Norse will charge you to check in a bag,
or to bring a carry on,
or to choose which seat
you want to sit in.
Meals will cost extra,
as will priority boarding and check-in.
Norse makes around $87 per passenger
on ancillaries on every flight,
around a fifth of all passenger revenue.
And has aims to become the
highest ancillary revenue
per passenger airline globally.
But any airline, including
the big legacy carriers,
can, and often do, unbundle
their ticket prices.
So much so that revenue from ancillaries
across the aviation industry
has doubled since 2013
to total over a hundred billion dollars.
So to really get prices down,
especially as a startup,
you need to go even further.
And for Norse,
that started with getting
these aircraft for cheap.
- It was really an asset play initially
where we got the assets
at historic low prices
and very flexible terms
- [George] That's CEO Bjorn Tore Larsen
who told me that Norse
has streamlined operations
in an attempt to minimize costs.
- We fly long haul only,
we fly one aircraft type,
the Dreamliner, only.
So all our crew are trained
on only one type of aircraft,
we only do one type of maintenance.
- The company also operates
some of its flights
from cheaper airports,
like flying out of Gatwick
instead of Heathrow,
though they do have a
slot at New York's JFK.
And instead of flying out
of and back to a fixed hub,
Norse's planes fly onward
from each destination.
- You don't have a lot of
costs that is associated
with a hub and spoke
operation where you are
into a much, much more complex
operation straight away.
- Now, all of these factors
have helped Norse get pricing down
and achieve profitability
for the first time this year.
But here's the thing, (snaps)
Norse isn't actually
always that much cheaper
than major legacy US carriers.
See, airline prices vary wildly
depending on how far in advance you book,
how long your stay is,
and whether you plan on
flying one-way or return.
But if you compare the
prices for this flight
between Norse, Delta, and United,
Norse averaged around
$615 and United was 660.
Now if you include the fact
that Delta and United's price
includes a carry-on bag and a meal,
which would cost you
upwards of $50 on Norse,
then that price gap soon starts to shrink.
So how are these legacy carriers
able to get their prices down?
- Because of the scale and the
amount of capacity they have
and that brings their unit cost down.
- [George] That's John Grant,
Chief Analyst at aviation data firm OAG.
- If a legacy airline has
got 1,500 economy seats
spread across seven flights during the day
then they're able to match that.
- Another reason is that
economy seats only make up
a small fraction of
legacy airlines cabins,
the rest being far more
profitable premium economy,
business, and first class seats.
And that kind of explains why
when I search for tickets around Labor Day
Norse was more expensive
than some major US rivals.
- Sometimes our prices
are going up a little bit
and that is basically because
the cabin is being filled.
So the last passenger is
actually paying quite a bit more
than the first passenger.
- Now recently, demand has been so strong
that there's been enough flyers
for both low cost carriers
and legacy carriers to be able to profit.
- The relative strength of the US dollar
has encouraged a lot of
North American visitors.
And we've been blessed
with just enough capacity.
- But as the summer
season draws to a close,
international demand is set to drop.
And that's got some wondering
whether these low cost long haul carriers
will be able to survive the winter.
Is it sustainable long term?
- No.
- [George] After all, other
airlines have in the past
tried and failed to make low
cost transatlantic flight
commercially sustainable.
For years Norwegian Air used to operate
a budget friendly route
between Europe and America.
But the company faced a
whole bunch of headwinds,
from operating Boeing planes
that were grounded during the MAX crisis
to trying to juggle a wide array of roots.
- They had embarked on rapid growth.
They had a short haul network
and a long haul network.
They spread themselves
too thinly too quickly.
- During the pandemic,
the company filed for
bankruptcy protection,
restructured, reduced its
fleet from 156 aircraft to 51,
and crucially, discontinued
long haul operations.
What's not certainly is how
sustainable this is long term.
What are your views?
- You're absolutely right,
It's yet to be proven and
it has not a great history.
- But here's the thing,
many of Norse's planes are
actually old Norwegian planes.
So is the company set
to suffer the same fate?
- I don't totally agree that
we are born out of the ashes,
because we are a brand new airline.
We have no hub and spoke operations,
we don't own, you know,
short haul operations
trying to put everything together.
It's very different.
- You still have winter coming,
and you've said yourself,
you know, demand fluctuates.
Are you worried about
some of the winter months?
- I'm always worried, that's my job,
you know, I'm born worried.
And we really have to be very careful.
It's easy to burn a lot of
money if you get things wrong.
- So how can these low cost
carriers survive winter?
Well, one option is to
chase the warmer weather
and adjust your routes.
And Norse plan on doing just that.
Opening up winter routes
to Barbados, Jamaica,
and even adding a new
route to Bangkok in Asia.
But shifting key routes when
you don't have many planes
can create another headache.
- Dipping in and dipping out of markets
is a relatively high risk strategy
because your brand
awareness and your presence
is not as large as the other carriers
who are there year round.
- So another tactic is to
try and carry more cargo,
providing there's more
cargo to be carried.
- We are definitely seeing
a better cargo market
typically during the
winter, but you don't know.
So you can't take that for granted.
- And if those fail, well,
hunker down for the cold months
and conduct your scheduled maintenance
while your fleet is out of use.
Norse told me that they'd
try all of these tactics,
but the aviation industry
can be pretty cutthroat.
And while low-cost carriers
brace for the winter,
legacy carriers will
capture every advantage.
- If the market becomes
a little bit tougher
those legacy carriers are not gonna say,
"The market's yours."
They're gonna compete
for every seat with you,
and that's a challenge.
(rhythmic music)